[Music]
hello and welcome to stoffe eco vision
there is me Sophie Shepard not set well
time is running out for us to handle
them by mental disarray that we have
created my guest today is convinced
there is a way out we simply need to
design it well I'm here with artist
innovator creative thinker Don arose a
hard day in his studio Don it's very all
right so I suppose there is no like
traditional way of explaining what you
do it's like a 24 first century sort of
merger because you unite what
environmentalism urban design technology
into something that doesn't quite have
like one name like how do you name what
you do yourself I don't I explore let's
try to let's try to figure out what it
could be why I'm the son of a math
teacher kicked out of fine art school
twice Mastan architecture a lot of
people telling me what I want could
never be done and and it's my job to
prove them wrong so you're right I think
new houses so so I think I think it's
sort of interesting to make connections
between art between design between
architecture between technology and and
making new links in order to activate
the world around us so I think indeed
when I was young when I was 16 my
parents always said you have to choose
yeah you have to choose art or choose
science or now I don't want to choose I
want to do it all so maybe it's more
about trying to find the combination or
making yeah new connections between all
those disciplines and be hybrid of our
time so you can really do anything you
want there's no limit to it now and
you're always sort of an amateur trying
to become an expert yeah and and that so
you're driven by curiosity rather than
definitions and and it was interesting
when I was a young broken innocent long
time ago I worked in a secondhand
bookstore not so far from here as a
student but sometimes I would work late
at night and I was a secondhand
bookstore and the train would already
leave so they would allow me to sleep in
the bookstore and there was one space it
was a little bit smaller than this face
which exactly fitted the one person
mattress and that space was the
Russian literature space Pushkin gold
Chekhov Nabokov Dostoevsky so I would
fall asleep being surrounded by these
great masters and you know I really feel
it's sort of influenced my dreams at
that time but it's it's still there yeah
so it's they're a big dreamer so yeah
exactly is this somehow there there in
my brain as well and that was easy to
read it were you just surrounded here
there was there was Russian literature
I'll find it yes oh yeah there yeah yeah
yeah I like Gogol I like the city
stories you like the crazy ones right
yeah but it's sort of the world is
brutal but it's also poetic and they're
sort of it's sort of brutal poetry and
they they have they have a tough flight
but they find their own beauty in it
it's something that would sort of
explain your style into words brutality
but poetry no I think what what
triggered me the stories is the notion
of the journey and to explore and trying
to find your own way in reality and I
want in reality is very confusing right
now we have rising sea level air
pollution traffic jam viruses in China
so how can we make sense of the world
again how can we add meaning to the
world and maybe that's why I create to
be sane and in order to improve so I'm
gonna go through many of your projects
to give the viewers good idea yeah what
is it that you do exactly so for
instance to smoke free Tower which is
literally like a tower that sort of
takes in air pollution and releases
clean air yeah
and it's a great thing and from Krakov
to Beijing and they're like big hit do
you think that it could be something
that you could put up in every corner in
every city of course and why why aren't
they doing it then oh because we live in
a world where two polluters for free so
what is the price of clean air and
you're right I think the importance of
clean air is getting more and more
attention kids have asthma in big cities
or people live shorter lives allergies
allergy yeah yeah and then you feel the
pressure of the polluted air so I became
inspired by small
by pollution and I really wanted to show
the beauty of clean air and by making
these clean air parks which are 20 to 70
percent more clean than the rest of the
city you create a sort of an oasis where
people can see the future could feel the
future and indeed to trigger the
question why is it not everywhere that's
exactly the meaning of that project yeah
so so you're getting the essence of the
project okay so you went further and
you're doing this thing called the
smoke-free bikes where don't put a
device on the bike that cleans there
mm-hmm
are they making any difference because
that's all I want to know cuz I want to
have kids in the future and I'm thinking
I want to bring them to you know like a
world where I know they will survive
yeah so the tower is a need for public
spaces which for everyone and at the
same time the bike sharing is becoming
very popular in Asia so we develop the
sort of device on the steering wheel
which sucks off polluted air cleans it
and releases it so you can cycle and not
be polluted a lot of people you know
want the car because of the pollution
but of course more cars more pollution
so we wanted to celebrate bicycle and we
wanted to promote it and also give it
some kind of lifestyle and some kind of
coolness and some kind of meaning that's
also as important that's the text so
yeah there you have conceptual stuff
like water leaf and what is that
basically that you you you sort of use
lights to flood public spaces and you're
saying well this is what's gonna be like
if the sea level is right right and it's
an amazing idea
yeah rather like this sort of like a
virtual flood amination of LEDs and
lenses which shows how high water level
would be in the future we all know
climate is changing we all know our
world is changing but it seems it's very
abstract people like one on our degrees
and it's it's a bit confusing the
numbers don't you think so by making it
a very physical and by making a
collective experience and we had fifty
sixty thousand people on one night you
know looking at it you activate people
to not be scared of the future but
curious so we do symposia can we
generate energy from the changing and
tide should we build floating cities so
I think the row of the art that I make
is to activate people and that they are
more feeling more connected to the
future and being part of the solution
instead of being sad or angry or waiting
so I guess like
every time someone like you tries to you
know sort of raise the awareness the big
question is do you only attract the
attention of what you said fifteen
thousand people watching it or do you
actually does that whatever it is that
you do actually spur them to act well
that's the reason why I make it art
artisan activator
yeah and sometimes there's sort of a
practical solution like small tree
that's like a local solution very
practical and sometimes it's more about
you know opening up the minds of the
people it's about showing the beauty or
the wonder I think it really depends on
the conversation I'm having you know the
the questions I'm being asked the thing
that inspires me at the moment the weird
thing about the future is the future is
not today
five percent less worse it's something
new what we don't know and and so we
first have to imagine the future in
order to get there so you don't feel
like feature is something rigid you
think it's like fluid and whatever it is
imagine we have to create it first in
our brain and then once you can imagine
it you can you know constructed engineer
and prototype and make it happen
but is it like hundred percent depending
on our thought and sort of visualizing
and realizing or is it like a 50/50 face
and whatever it is that you do what is
it that you built it's a good question I
don't know but I'm fourth for sure I
know we first have to imagine it
otherwise we don't get there so this
whole follow the flow think is a BS we
know is not working anymore it's
crashing no sort of things are crashing
regarding climate change definitely yeah
and we don't have a solution and you
know I'm a professor at universities my
students are mad you know because they
need to spend so much time and love and
energy in fixing the plastic in the
ocean the air pollution so they can they
kind of creates they can only correct
and that's not a good age to be in you
know a good area to be in so let's talk
about to anywhere technical things more
but you're saying yeah okay this whole
our deal with climate change is not why
but how right so what do you do I'm so
tired of the why we all like why should
everybody knows the why forget about the
why we know we have to be sustainable
okay so there are some people who still
disagree but you know they'll figure it
out
so it's about the how how do we make it
happen and how do you make a world which
is better for me how do you help
rephrase that question with what it is
that you do well I use technology to
bring solutions I use art and design to
show the beauty of the new world so that
people will accept it more evenly and
I'm trying to make new connection which
before never existed what do you mean
new connection well for example the
spaceways laughs it's a project I'm
working on very intensively now with
Asia and NASA at the space agencies
there's more than 8.1 million kilo of
space junk floating around our universe
what it is it's basically what like
green light we started launching
satellites Rockets from 1953 years put
Nick Apollo Chinese Russian American lot
of countries and they started to collide
so you have more than 8.1 million kilo
of junk floating around our universe and
because they have a high speed 27
thousand kilometres per hour when they
hit an existing satellites like a bob so
it's a threat to our day-to-day
communication and nobody really knows
how to fix it so we launched space race
lab to visualize real time where the
space junk is with light green light
right yeah it's great with your hat
right and it's really like it's right
there phase 2 is to fix it so we finally
have an official mission now to develop
a sort of small cube satellite with a
net like I'd like a Fisher captures fish
it's more complicated is it how can you
fix well then we grab it okay capture it
and but then the second phase is okay
then once we have it there but what
should we do with it maybe it's not a
problem but it got really shor do you
get rid of it I mean what you pull it
the Earth's instead of the atmosphere
what you do with it that's the what
exercise so if you have a net that you
have two space junk capture something
and it's floating here and then you have
the earth atmosphere so when in a
controlled way with a little you know
engine you can it hits the earth
atmosphere and a controlled reentry
what happens then it's good you know
what else yeah it burns burns okay so
and what happens when something burns it
gives combustion what's late lights okay
so that's what we're
now waste is light so we're creating
artificial shooting stars okay as a
replacement for traditional fireworks
hmm the universe and we have a new way
of fireworks so we're going to
government do by spending 8.2 million
u.s. dollar on fireworks every year now
on 70 70 millions there's a rotate we're
going to the minister ministers and say
take that budget that you're already
spending and you spend it on this is a
rose garden project you clean up the
universe and you have a new way of fire
what did I say the ministers they didn't
say no yet so we're really good there
yeah so I think in three to five years
we will have that realized and so am I
smarter than a czar Naza no because
they're really smart but what I can do
as a designer as an artist is look at it
in a different way
and say it's not waste it's a shooting
star so I designed the last 2% and that
changes the project completely and
suddenly you know there's Disney their
cities there so you make new connections
between space industry and tourism
cities etc that's the stuff that we're
doing here then that's the stuff that
really excites me so what made you all
of a sudden sweet switch from my climate
change and smog to taking care of the
waste an atmosphere Wow I want to live
in a world where where pollution does
not exist you know and I think it's
weird that we accept pollution air
pollution water pollution space
pollution especially space you know
that's our new frontier we should learn
from the sort of mistakes that we make
them planet Earth and and everybody has
a right for clean space don't you think
it should be something that they sort of
human in caseware to overpopulate so it
yeah refute it or you know that's it's
unacceptable so I was walking up where
we're now here in the studios we have a
team of project managers designers
engineers architects and I was walking
around as we were working on a lot of
other project and I saw this huge black
image with a lot of white dots and this
big dot in the middle and I asked what's
that you know it looked like this sort
of abstract American painting this
Jackson Pollock and they said that space
junk it's an eight point one milk it up
I'm like what that's crazy so that's
typically a project we initiated I spend
my own money and time on it and now the
clients are coming in investing so it's
it's gonna be fascinating
you know bit crazy but but good yeah Don
we're gonna take a short break right now
when we're back we'll continue talking
to Don Drew's a hardier about the future
stay with us
[Music]
and we're back with innovative sinker
artists designer Tom throws harder here
in his studio Don what do you say to all
those like skeptics that are like you
know there is no climate change you know
it's always been there this is a cycle
you guys just don't remember yeah this
is OBS and this is to scare people off
okay theories how the weather is on
their planet because on my planet it's
it's very concrete you know people are
scared of change and that's very normal
and people have to get used to new ideas
that's also very normal but I think we
shouldn't hide or be scared but it
should be curious and invest in new
ideas to survive it in the end it's
about that and it's not just that it's
necessary it's also fun and and there's
sort of a joy in making radical ideas
happen and they're sort of a joy in
having people look at reality in a
different way and open up their mind and
that can be via a book or a movie but it
can also be about public art and design
so design is not just a chair or a lamp
or a table but design is about improving
life and it's and it's really fun to
work on that as well but I feel like
you're so different from every other
modern art artists or instalay Terr that
I've met because there's so much about
self-expression and the commentary
please sort that event yeah because
you're like me and my teddy bear yeah
that's like great I had a teddy bear
yeah yeah I cried when I was yeah great
yeah no I'm not sorry that's right so it
is definitely about me and my feelings
of course but I want to talk as much
about the we the world as about to me my
personal relationship with that I think
that I think you know when you do
something that gives something back to
the people to society it's somehow it's
way more rewarding then if I just do it
for myself I just I don't think it's
that dangerous I don't think I'm that
interesting in that way but everything
that it is that you're doing right now
which is like really looking forward
into the future and shaping gate for the
best right is it something that happened
with the past like 5/10 years when we
started talking about the climate change
okay
yeah I think it's definitely the
something of this age like maybe twenty
years ago you would be about me and my
teddy bear yeah of you will buy a Hummer
and we'll be really cool I don't know
how it's review guys but if you buy all
comers very cool in the nine days yeah
but I'm sorry Hummer now very
interesting are these our notion of what
is beauty or what is luxury or what is
what is what is normal has changed and
and sustainability isn't that not not
just that word but it's about that we
are aware that's you we are us we are
connected and if I do something stupid
to you in a way it will influence me as
well and so the more you understand that
relationship we are in whether we like
it or not but it's you know we're all
crew on passengers perhaps knots
passenger like like we're all part of it
whether we like it or not and the more
you are aware of that relationship the
more you can interact and play that's
that's that's life that's that's it yeah
I think internet did all of that right
because I was talking to this great lady
she's very huge in artificial
intelligence and we were saying that
everything that's going on right now
especially with the ia and Internet it
really reminds us of when they invented
the atomic bomb only yeah you know when
it blew up you know only blew up in a
certain place but if something were to
blow up now what we don't understand is
that it's gonna go bad everywhere yes
are we have a wheelie reared
relationship with technology I think
right now today you me all of us we've
becomes a robot food we're feeding our
hopes our dreams our desires our money
to computer screens and what do we get
back you know I likey that's that's a
bad deal so - technology jumping out of
the screen when is technology helping me
to keep me healthier to keep me in for
tour to keep me you know feeling
connected and I miss that so we will
live in an area the post screen area
where we will look less at all these
screens and and it will be more in
harmony or it will help us more yeah but
I'm really tired of you know feeding
machines
yeah I'm just robots food because like
everyone I speak to right now they're
pretty much convinced that this is an
irreversible thing where we're gonna
become half robots and then event
we're gonna be robots and then
artificial intelligence is the future I
mean I don't really believe in the whole
scary crowd singularity period thing but
I do feel like there's something that is
beyond my control in terms of what will
happen to me as a human being but it's a
good comment so I think there's a gorge
rovol scenario were dominated but
there's also Leonardo da Vinci scenario
where we use technology to fly and I was
thinking about it this morning I was at
TWA terminal New York Airport this is
beautiful all terminal built in 1971-72
and it was built in a time when people
were curious about the future you know
we would go to the moon we had the
Jetsons the concorda people were curious
about the future you can feel that in
that building and it's weird today that
somehow we're sort of scared of the
future and the robots take over our jobs
or will dominate us like you just said
or the Chinese come and buy everything
or and I think I hope and I think that
the project that we do here that I do
help people to become curious against -
towards the future they are part of it
you know it's not just like oh it's the
robots and that is that the world we
want to live in no so yes what you're
saying is absolutely scenario but it's
just one of the scenarios and we are
going to be a part of that we are part
of that conversation because this is
something that worries me so much like I
suppose like curiosity's won't think
that is going away from us right now and
you're trying to sort of in your own way
reinstall it in people yeah but also I
feel like the hope in the future because
you're absolutely right before people
who are like no matter how bad things
were you're like it's gonna be better
tomorrow and now you know we don't know
what's gonna happen so we're looking the
future like do I want to be there I mean
I don't know how do you bring back that
sense of agency not only curiosity but
the sense that you're in control well
first of all you have to decide that
you're not just the consumer but you're
a maker so you make decisions you make
things you make choices and then that
way you influence the world around you
so you need to take ownership and you
need to accept that you're part of it
and the second is and that's the beauty
of making things making
project there's such a beauty in putting
an idea realizing and putting it out
there when we place the first smoke-free
tower in Beijing and and made this clean
air parks before that whoo
can you do that are you allowed sure
yeah so you sort of throw a rock in the
river you create your ripples and you
start surfing on them and and by doing
that we just made a statement and we
showed that clean air locally could be
possible so we set a new standard and
indeed we got questions why is it then
everywhere what's the price of clean air
we had Chinese people capturing the wind
in bottles glasses and they would sell
it all this so you activate a discussion
and I think if you approach reality in
that way and show the beauty of clean
air clean water and clean energy yeah
you you you you you you feel more part
of it and you are part of it and that
that's very rewarding yeah but it's
really the human nature that I question
more because somehow no matter what kind
of genius things we humans invent like
from dynamite to Facebook we manage to
make everything catastrophic and no
matter like whether you have iPhone 1035
in your hand or not we still keep
killing each other for a piece of land
and piece of land we can do good things
we can do bad things yeah it's true but
do you question on the hey okay this is
here's it here's an idea for your new
project or installation tell me my new
project how do is synchronize the
technological evolution with a human
evolution exactly so you need
technological innovation and you also
need social innovation and that's
absolutely right so you need to create
an environment where what you do is not
a negative impact on the other and and
that that that is a certain awareness
and that's a fuzzy topic and a fuzzy
word I'm a highly aware of that we just
launched our new Holocaust project
Holocaust memorial absolutely beautiful
yeah 140,000 people were arrested and
deported and murdered here in elephants
and 75 years ago they was liberation of
the death camps outreach and the Dutch
government commissioned us can you make
a monument for for those people for that
the important moment in time and what
was interesting is that this was not
about function
but this was about the memory and
remembering them but it was also about
the future and showing the importance of
freedom to our generation which did not
really experienced war in that way
anyway so we we took actually the notion
of the rock so at a Jewish tradition and
a grave if you don't place flowers but
you place a rock and that was really
interesting so we started to absorb the
rocks with fluorescent pigments light
emitting pigments which under very
special lights become light emitting and
hundred four thousand victims on the
four thousand rocks which sort of glow
and light as they sort of breathe and
what I'm trying to say is it created the
place you know I've seen Holocaust
survivors come there with their
grandchildren sharing stories and these
days it's like goose bumps here and
after that the artwork all these rocks
spread to all the hundred seventy
municipalities in the Netherlands where
these people were deported so it went
from very national big to super local
and to see all the ceremonies that
people organized and reading the names
and the traditions and the stories and I
went to them incognito they didn't know
every single of them no no no it was too
much but some of them and it was so
humbling to make something and that
people take ownership and and they start
to wonder history future what's my role
on it so I think there was a beautiful
example how art and design can activate
and and help people to remember that
they're part of the world yeah it's not
just waiting for government or being mad
well you tackle so many ideas in the
studio that are born and then you make
them come to life but then when I
started and I finish it is of course
large large groups of people but I
really wonder which ideas get born into
this office that even for you yeah
they're like you know way too far out
there
that that have they can't or haven't
come to life oh man there's a whole
archive of Oh
geoengineering where to control its to
engineering so in a way climate change
for me is in there was not bad design
you and I we have created it there with
our pollution like airplane is bad
engineering well no the weather the way
the weather is behaving or the climate
sorry the climate is behaving is is for
me bad design because it's not very good
for us and a lot of animals and plant so
can we design weather can we design
climate change can we actively
participate we've designed it
unconsciously and we've our pollutions
before factory can we turn it around the
problem is we don't know real the impact
of that yet and you can be really right
but those are really wrong so it's a big
ethical discussion like should you do
that
I think that's an incredibly fascinating
topic that I haven't made up my mind yet
about I'm gonna come back for another
interview just on that topic yeah let's
do it yeah and actually the Russian and
Middle East are very active in these
kind of things you're coming to Moscow
[Music]
let's check with saison so we're gonna
do that interview when you come to me
yeah yeah you'll want to do G oh that's
cool yeah yeah it's may tell us about
the dress that you designed that becomes
transparent ones that are not on your
list yeah I was thinking why didn't he
design it like a t-shirt or a suit for
someone about opposite sex to see Donna
it's not a very known project but we yes
we made a garment for ladies which have
how how much you like somebody the more
transparent you become and indeed then
the guys we're like hey what what about
what about us what about me so we made a
suit for men yeah but that only becomes
transparent when they lie that was that
was that was a bad purchase because it
was a good bad project all right well
done thank you so much it was a good
season good luck with everything
[Music]